[Musique]
elle à peine 13 ans mais la jeune anna à
le doigté et la maîtrise d'une
violoniste professionnel originaire de
hong kong
elle fait partie du groupe sélect des
prodiges de la musique c'est sûr douik
performe un très haut niveau dès leur
plus jeune âge
à 7 ans elle était déjà dans une classe
à part et à 12 ans ont livré à jouer
devant des salles combles
[Musique]
son secret l'amour de la musique et la
concentration à éviter dans le cadre du
concours musical international de
montréal en a accepté de participer à
une étude clinique en cours au
laboratoire de neuro psychologie de
l'université de montréal elle a passé
différents tests psychologiques
une résonance magnétique on cherche en
fait à voir si les prodiges ont un
cerveau différent des autres
par exemple est-ce qu'ils sont nés avec
des prédispositions finalement à
apprendre rapidement la musique qu à se
démarquer des autres
jusqu'ici les ce bout de dix sept jeunes
prodiges et de 17 musées professionnels
ont été analysés
premier constat leur quotient
intellectuel est très semblable
on s'attendait à voir des différences
entre eux qu'il y avait une étude qui a
démontré que les produits musicaux avait
un côté intellectuel très supérieur à la
moyenne
pour l'instant c'est parce qu'on observe
sur le plan physiologique les cerveaux
des prodiges se démarque légèrement ce
qu'on trouve c'est au niveau du cerveau
on voit effectivement une connectivité
différentes et qu'ils apprennent
beaucoup plus vite
en fait c'est la capacité de travail et
la concentration qui les distingue
vraiment un à pratiquer cinq heures par
jour y apprend deux fois plus rapidement
que professionnel
c'est pas magique c'est pas dieu qui
leur parlent donc dû avoir des
mécanismes qui met en route qui sont
chez eux vraiment exacerbée on aimerait
bien les connaître
le revers de la médaille si les prodiges
atteint rapidement les plus hauts
standards
une fois au sommet ils ont tendance à
plafonner pour rattraper et qui
d'ailleurs sont des noirs certain de
continuer à être virtuose parce que il y
en a d'autres
ils ont plus les selles mais la jeune
anna confiance depuis l'âge de 5 ans est
libre où ils sont publics
il est convaincu qu'elle pourra
continuer à le faire ici norma grondin
radio canada montréal